this summer we're getting honest about
summer blockbusters past and present
this is honest trailers blockbuster
summer Mel lost his wife and got mad
then he lost his wife and got lethal now
he'll lose his wife and get brave in
Braveheart journey to medieval Scotland
a place where the men are loud
the women are silent and everyone's hair
is grody when their land is taken by
history snootiest conquerors Scottish
rebels have Roberts one of my goddesses
William Wallace will get some payback
but there's no defense against this true
Scotsman he'll yell you into a frenzy
he'll stare you into his bed it's just I
say he's down I mean because of the way
you're looking and he will rock you
[Music]
strap it in for a tale all about taking
back Liberty that takes every Liberty
with the true story because if it were
accurate
there'd be no kilts bagpipes or face
paint no wife princess or plot Center
cuckoldry I will bless this marriage by
taking the bride into my face and
Wallace's big speech before a battle was
actually behold I have brought you into
a ring now Carolyn dance as well as you
can huh
but you're not here to learn you're here
for all the hot sweaty action whether
it's man on man man on horse or arrow in
but Brave Hearts got more violence than
you can shake a field full of dick sad
that's what I'm talking about do you
like torture you do well thank you for
being honest weirdo now strap yourself
in because Mel is adding to his
bizarrely long resume of pay
in an endless torture finale that makes
it clear what drew him to the story rock
him hey you know what they say follow
your passion huh so gear up for your
dad's 300 that's the kind of Hollywood
epic they don't really make anymore
where the armies are real The Scotsman
are Australian and you forgive all of
its many flaws because it gets you
pumped every single time
[Applause]
[Music]
USA USA Scotland Scotland story killed
longer King bad guy that something about
mutton have fun storming the castle
Prince Adam let Padme
tormund medium Spain when the drugs hit
[Music]
[Applause]
I used to be an adventurer like you
until I took an arrow to the chest and
an axe to the hand and another axe to
the gut and Game of Thrones
[Music]
white Klansmen sure Mel was almost 40
playing a guy in his early 20s but to be
fair people aged hard back then I mean
look at this guy he's 35 hey screen
junkies tired of arguing over who the
strongest characters in fiction are
without any real numbers to fall back on
we made a scientist extract hard data on
their abilities then made them run a
gauntlet of challenges to see who comes
out on top in an all-new series power
levels check out the first episode now
they may take our lives but they'll
never take our freedom